Halloween parade bro the one night of  the year we fit in get back what part of  moving the shadows don't you understand  I've never seen anything like this  before  guys I got a lead on what's going on  since its honor this one I was building  on we've gotta be good  you are rhinoceros and you're uh huh I'm  a little piggy well well  what's your name Casey Jones you do guys  like a thing if the purple ooze can turn  humans into animals it could turn us  into humans we don't have to be stuck  down here forever if there's chance that  make us humans for turtles whether you  like it or not gear up guys  this isn't working we keep failing  keep the team unified and you shall  always succeed  let's light them up  Oh  I don't know if this is such a good plan  you're forgetting something yeah  company karabast  well